وصل رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشي سوناك
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه في زياره لم يعلن
عنها مسبقا وهي زيارته الاولى الى
اوكرانيا
رئيس الاوكرانيه الذي قال في حسابه على
تليغرام انه منذ الايام الاولى للحرب كانت
اوكرانيا وبريطانيا العظمى حيفتين قويتين
واضاف ان هناك مع رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
خلال اجتماع اليوم اهم القضايا بالنسبه
للبلدين وللامن العالمين
هذا هو كده رئيس وزراء بريطانيا ريشي
سوناك ان بلاده ستستمر في تقديم دعمها
العسكري لوكرانيا كما اعلن عن تزويد ثياب
بانظمه جديده للدفاع الجوي تتضمن 120
مدفعيه مضاد للطائرات
و 300 مليون جنيه استرليني من الدعم
العسكري وسنفعل شيئا نفسه مره اخرى العام
القادم بينما تنجحون في سد القوات الروسيه
على الارض تتدمر منازلكم ومستشفياتكم
ومحطه الطاقه لديكم
وللمساعدتكم في الدفاع عن انفسكم نقدم
اليوم حزمه دعم جديده للدفاع الجوي بما في
ذلك مئه وعشرون وحده مدفعيه مضاده
للطائرات
ومعدلات مضاده للطائرات المسيره
مراسلنا المعتز بالله حسن المعتز بالله عن
زياره رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الى اكياب
وما حملته من دلائل ورسائل
خلال زياره رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف هذه الزياره التي
لم يعلن عنها سابقا جرى فيها مؤتمر صحفي
لكل من الرئيس الاوكراني ورئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الرئيس الاوكراني كان واضحا في
تبيان امتنانه لهذه الزياره وشكر بريطانيا
على ما سماه وقوفها الى جانب اوكرانيا في
هذه الحربه وقال رئيس الوزراء رئيس
الاوكراني ان ااه البلدين متفقان معا على
الوقوف وجن وجه لوجه في ظل هذه التحديات
واكد على ضروره همم ان همم يكون هذا
التعاون مستمر فيما يتعلق بموضوع الطاقه
الرئيس الاوكراني شدد على ان روسيا بقصفها
قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا هي لا تستهدف فقط
الاوكرانيين وانما ايضا تستهدف امن الطاقه
في اوروبا واكد على او اعاده تاكيد على
ضروره ان يكون هناك سقف موضوع اسعار
الطاقه الروسيه اللي تشعر روسيا كما قال
بالخسائر بالخسائر من جهاته رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني اكد على ان لندن تقف الى جانب
كياب في هذه الحرب واشدد على انها ماضيه
في تقديم الدعم المالي والعسكري لاوكرانيا
خصوصا ان الرئيس الوزراء البريطاني تحدث
عن انه همم سيكون هناك مؤتمر في الصيف
القادم في لندن واتمنى ان تكون هذه الحرب
قد انتهت للالتفاته الى مسماه همم بناء
اوكرانيا من جديد ايضا انتقد تدمير روسيا
لقطاع الطاقه الاوكراني واكد على استمرار
همم دعم كيف المعدات العسكريه كان هناك
حديث ايضا عن همم ان هذا هذه المعدات سوف
تستمر لندن في تقديمها همم
باجيره الوقوف امام او الى جانب اوكرانيا
وكانت بريطانيا كما نذكر طلبت روسيا في
قمه العشرين ايضا بالخروج والانسحاب من
الاراضي اوكرانيه كانت هذه الزياره همم
باختصار اا تبادل فيها الطرفان التاكيد
على التعاون المشترك والمواقف المشتركه
همم ضد ما سموه الاعتداء الروسي على
اوكرانيا
حسن كنت معنا من كيف